dans un communiqué qu'ils étaient joints
à cette cassette le djihad lancé deux
accusations contre le gouvernement
français 1
les opposants irakiens expulsés vers
bagdad n'ont pas été libérés les deux
opposants de la france au but aux ordres
qui viennent de washington
nous allons revenir maintenant sur ces
deux points avec d'abord cette
confirmation les deux irakiens sont bien
autorisé à revenir à paris dès cette
rentrée universitaire c'est ce qu'avait
affirmé hier soir je vous le disais le
quai d'orsay
c'est ce qu'a confirmé tout à l'heure
l'ambassadeur d'irak en france où la
patience voici faouzi ramena souriant
quand il était officiellement étudiant à
paris en compagnie de hassan kheireddine
étudiant lui aussi mais en fait tous les
deux opposants au régime d'irakiens ils
fuyaient leur pays nous avions rencontré
à bagdad après leur expulsion au moment
où la demande du gouvernement français
les autorités irakiennes les avait remis
en liberté il était manifestement marqué
par la période qu'il venait de vivre
ils nous ont affirmé qu'ils avaient été
bien traités et qu'ils étaient
totalement libres de leurs mouvements
le nez l'autre parlait d'ailleurs de
revenir en france pour poursuivre leurs
études pour la france ni pour mon oui
c'est très important
et bien sûr il fallait avant tout
régulariser leur dossier en irak et dans
ces pays les formalités administratives
sont généralement très longue
cette moisson face et aujourd'hui enfin
tout semble réglé ils ont obtenu leur
visa de sortie pour revenir en france ce
que nous confirme la basler d'irak à
paris paul fort juhasz qui fonçait à
layrac
quels sont les drills faire partir comme
elle veut quand elle veut vous êtes sûr
que c'est la chose qui vous dirait si on
pouvait les voir
oui vous pouvez la voir vous pouvez
faire l'interview quant à paris à bagdad
ou bien qu'elle veut venir ici nous
devons venir ici à paris mais vous êtes
sûr qu'ils vont venir
oui certes mais ils viennent parce
qu'ils sont libres parce que c'est un
accord entre vous et le quai d'orsay
l'eau il n'y a pas d'accord il ya le
grâce sans condition et le pot partie
comme elle veut